hi
hello hey we're the try guys and these
are our essentials
[Music]
this is my adventure fanny pack
i have a two-year-old son so we go on
adventures together anytime you go on an
adventure it's important to bring
the following things snacks peanut
butter and jelly sandwich preferred
also peanut butter crackers some water
and a little sippy cup sunblock
obviously
little baby mask tiny little baby
sunglasses
hey ow and of course
raisins this is a herschel fanny pack
it's
you know it's stylish it's classy i mean
if i were
a cool guy i'd wear it like a a side bag
a little cool man purse
daddy purse a durse
this right here it's my sourdough
starter his name is sven
we've been through a lot together let's
uh crack open and take a little whiff
oh that smells nasty yeah it's got that
good stank
i got into baking after we did a video
called try guys baked bread without a
recipe
my bread didn't do very well but i was
captivated by
the baker and showing how he made bread
it's
so simple it's just four ingredients
flour water salt and yeast but you don't
even need yeast if you have a natural
starter
which is just combining flour and warm
water and letting it sit on the counter
for a while
until it gets real nice and stinky
that's how you oh
third essential is a sleeping mask as
parent of a newborn
my nap game is strong so i can take a
nap
at any time of day wherever i am all i
need is this
just slap it on lean back
it's also great for planes when planes
were a thing this one
in particular is very soft it's called
alaska
bear i wonder if i got it on alaskan air
there's a bunch of scratchy ass sleep
masks out there that are
total bs invest in a nice one get
yourself some good stuff this has got
silk on it nice on your face nice on
your eyes
it's the most luxury you can have when
you're only getting
four hours of sleep and have spit up all
over your chest
wow bam bam
something that is very essential to my
life are these hot sauces they do have
my face
i do make them of course i endorse them
but i actually
do eat them all the time first i made
the chicken sauce and then i made the
burger sauce right now more of a burger
sauce boy
to be honest uh even though my love of
fried chicken precedes me
i love buffalo wings even though they
hurt my tongue i love buffaloing so much
so i wanted to make like
a buffalo sauce so this one's kind of
like a buffalo has a little ranch it's
got some sour cream powder in it so it
does have to be refrigerated unlike most
sauces
it's vinegary it's savory and then this
one
is currently my favorite because it's
like kind of smoky and mustardy
that's so good and here's the real thing
i have a geographic
tongue i'll let you get a close-up of it
in a second you want to see it
there's these little weird pink or white
shapes that appear on my tongue
that's why it's called geographic kind
of looks like a map
as a kid anything acidic like grapefruit
juice
orange juice hot sauce hurts my tongue
and i was like why is that and then at
one point i went to the dentist
and he was like ah you have a geographic
tongue i was like huh
if you sat on a plus side you probably
also taste more depth in foods that you
eat because your tongue is so sensitive
and i'm like maybe
i've only ever had this tongue so i
can't tell you if my tongue is better
than your tongue
but science says it is all right
godspeed little one go go go
[Music]
the nintendo switch boom
okay so all my life i have always
been a game boy kid specifically i had
two older brothers
they always had the bigger consoles and
because i was a lot younger than them
they really wouldn't let me play the
playstation or the nintendo 64 et cetera
so i got myself a game boy and i got so
into just
playing video games by myself and as the
game boy advance came out in game of ds
i just kind of followed every single
portable nintendo machine and then the
switch came out and
i just love it i love how nintendo is
all about fun i'm not like a gamer gamer
you play mario kart with your friends
you play smash brothers with your
friends it is about
a community the other games are a little
more about like i'm the best whereas i
feel like nintendo's about let's all
have fun
this video is not a commercial for
nintendo but i will
i'll i'll still endorse it
[Music]
first up boom a little bit of a
shameless plug here
t more specifically my tea is called
zadoko tico
so first a backstory i live with chronic
pain it's a
autoimmune disease called ankylosing
spondylitis basically
makes my body very stiff a lot of
inflammation makes it very hard to sleep
so
i made a tea that was perfect for me
it's an anti-inflammatory wake-up tea
it's delicious but it's got turmeric
sarsaparilla
ginger makes my body feel good makes my
brain feel good because genuinely
i never sleep i drink this so much
this is the actual bag that i have in my
house i have two of these
and i'm not kidding this is this is tea
and i've already had half of it so
that's about two pounds of tea
[Music]
these teas are just delicious enough to
drink on their own i
i have nothing against you putting milk
in your tea however
these do not require them a lot of
people are like oh t's too bitter it's
because you're having [ __ ]
cheap tea and you're over steeping it
it's okay loose leaf is just better
it's grown-up tea it's time to grow up i
believe in you you can do it
you can keep those i got i have a
two-pound bag
[Music]
these are absolutely essential to my
life to my brain
these are my journals i carry these with
me everywhere i go
it's just a system for organizing my
extremely scattered brain
i genuinely would be lost in life
without this this is how i kept track of
producing our documentary
this is how i creatively made notes on
our documentary
especially during the quarantine like i
needed this
to just because every day bled together
this is my tether
to reality it's really fun to just go
through old ones like you'll rediscover
old ideas this is weird i just outlined
the movie elf from memory
i'm like i'm just gonna write the movie
elf and dissect it and figure out how it
was structured and it's
it's structured quite well
this next one very important to my life
anyone who knows me these
are my boobs and bops hello my
beautifuls
this is random tchotchkes i love stupid
[ __ ] i've been collecting them my whole
life
and they don't necessarily have meaning
other than the fact that they have
meaning to me all right we'll start with
this this is a dumpling
uh that i put a glitter cowboy hat on i
got this glitter cowboy hat at a party
in college
i don't remember the party but i
remember the hat
this is a figurine of steve carell in
the 40 year old virgin
when you press it it talks oh no the
batteries out i gotta do something about
that
this mother you don't want to know about
him
these are great okay i was in a
bookstore in rural new jersey
and for 50 cents each spice girls in my
pocket
what a steal this one ginger spice has
the best stuff
this is a quote from her my favorite
word is existentialism
i can't say it and i'm not quite sure
what it means
it doesn't get better than that uh
let's see if baby spice has any good
quotes
[Music]
no essential list is complete without
one's pets
this is my dog pesto i have three pups
all of them are shelter rescue
adoptions and they are the loves of my
life
we got pesto when he was about four
months old people didn't really pay
attention to him in the pound because
i don't know if you can see but he has
this big scar on his back but
i immediately saw how adorable and what
a great loving personality he had
so he became mine and
he is just another great example of the
amazing animals you can get
from adoption centers and rescues and
pounds so
adopt don't shop i'm a big sucker for
letting the pup sleep in the bed
i know a lot of people want to keep them
you know crate trained and give them
parameters but you know i'm a real
loving parent i'm the one that you go to
when you want
ice cream when you want to hug over here
costume over here there you go
it's a real fashion cover right there
i brought another item from my closet
that i consider something that's both
signature and staple
it's this leather jacket i got a few
years ago that i really love
i wear it everywhere and you know i
think a lot of people when you start
exploring your style expression you feel
like you have to divide things between
comfort
and courage and one of the lessons i've
learned is to start combining the two
feelings
so you want to find things that make a
mark and that people can comment on that
you feel like you can wear
in your sleep and this just happens to
be that the first few times i wore this
i remember people said wow wow look at
that jacket that jacket's really cool
but the hundredth time i wore it they
just said oh that's eugene's jacket and
that's just part of his personality
i think that's a really awesome thing
that style and apparel can do
for one's language it's a way in which
we communicate
especially with me being more
self-assured and coming out of the
closet officially i
wanted to make sure that my closet came
with me
if you know what i mean
kimchi y'all i've seen these gq videos
before
and the first thing i thought when i saw
one was my item is kimchi
i cannot survive without a huge old jug
of kimchi in my refrigerator now not
every korean is as obsessed with kimchi
as i am many koreans certainly are
but if you are not familiar with kimchi
it's a fermented spicy cabbage
i would equate it to pickles in other
culture but really i
i would say it's more like a wine or
cheese
this is a pro tip one of the best things
in a kimchi jar
is actually the kimchi juice do not
throw that away
do not pour it out if you're making any
sort of stir fry or if you're doing a
korean dish
pour this [ __ ] into it it is like not
liquid gold it's like liquid
garnet i would advise you to google your
nearest market particularly a korean one
if it's near you
like an h mart and literally grab
any of the labels that you can't read i
guarantee you it's gonna be better than
what you get
at a whole foods or trader joe's the
best thing about getting kimchi from a
cream market too
is that is way less expensive than
getting it from a western style grocery
store
the asian mafia is going to descend upon
me and and
strike me down for letting all the the
non-asians know
about that thank you gq so much for
having us
this has been the essentials that the
try guys cannot live without
much like my dog in this meat stick